every day I'm trying to convince one
person
that life is a billion times better than
they've decided because they were
unfortunate to have life situations or
most common cynical or pessimistic
or negative parents and circumstances
that made them believe the propaganda of
negativity Vayner Nation I'm extremely
excited about this episode of the
podcast because this is a gentleman that
I've started to get to know a little bit
but have admired from afar quite a bit
not only because of the company built
and in the category he built it in and
navigated it but you know I really do
enjoy getting to know people through
shared relationships and I've just
always liked the way people have spoken
about Daniel behind his back
especially people I know that know what
I care about which is like look there's
a lot of good entrepreneurs out there a
lot of people build nice businesses and
big businesses and but I just kind of
like
nice people and things of that nature
and so it's really not pay a lot of
money to get there Gary like it's been a
lot of bribes too
uh get them to say those nice things
it's true that sentence probably I made
at least thirty seven thousand dollars
on
um it's uh no really my friend it's
really nice to have you here I always
like to give the guests the first two
minutes to paint a picture of context to
the audience so you know both personally
or professionally or anywhere you want
to take it Daniel why don't you tell
everybody who you are and a little bit
about yourself and your journey
thank you again very pleased also be
with you I've been also hearing your
name for so many years
and then I was too slow to connect with
you because obviously you just uh done
an incredible job and I just only wish
we had uh started working with you many
years ago well listen we got 40 50 60
more years together my friend so
unofficially officially when did you
start uh on this journey as like these
social media Maiden labor I wrote a book
in 2009 called crush it that
made an argument that YouTube and
Twitter would create a micro economy
where people could make a hundred
thousand dollars a year really being
themselves or talking about their deep
niches and as you remember much like
what may start happening here the
economy was in a very tricky spot after
the crisis and my argument was
hey this internet thing this social
media thing is much much much bigger
than people think and a for you
individual human there might be some
opportunity but B for every business and
brand this is the parallel of what
happened when the radio lost its
leverage to the television I believe
that social is going to eat up a lot of
the marketing realities and you know a
lot of people didn't believe me and a
lot of people thought it was you know I
mean there's not a single you could type
in right now Facebook Twitter Snapchat
Instagram and just put a fad and you'll
read a thousand articles of Facebook's a
fad YouTube's a fad Twitter's a fad the
internet is a fad you remember you and I
were going through those years so you
know I think I think I had a lot of
conviction and was quite loud about a
lot of things that ended up being true
that people didn't think was true even
more recently tick tock four years ago
I'm like the Pied Piper on LinkedIn and
every other platform that tick tock's
real real real people thought it was a
platform for teenage girls dancing and
so I think you know know the receipts as
my favorite football head coach Robert
Sala talks about the receipts over the
last decade I think have given me that
opportunity
I think I've been
here for them but yeah I certainly so so
is Lee from that moment anyway
um do you want to just share a little
bit about yeah I think I think people
will really enjoy you know the context
of who you are and then we'll go into a
series of modern questions sure so I'm
best known as the founder of kind
healthy stock company I started from
nothing uh built it into a pretty
significant company
but I and I was at every stage of the
game from inception when I was a
one-person operation of a company that
launched kind all the way to what it is
today but I actually don't identify
myself
as the big guy from kind of by the time
as I was the guy that was carrying the
boxes even before kind was found peace
works and as a social entrepreneur
resource is a company that promotes
piece through business that brings
Neighbors in confidence work together
and use business as a force for bringing
Israelis Palestinians Egyptians
jordanians together we have ventures in
Indonesia and Sri Lanka in South Africa
and Mexico lots of mistakes lots of
lessons from which kind sprung and
through the lessons and then out of
success I built a lot of uh Civic
platforms I co-founded a movement called
One Voice which gave birth
to the largest Civic movement in
existence today in both uh within
Israeli and Palestinian societies and
most recently I've been very involved in
the United States and
both Building Bridges but also like
helping amplify the voices of moderation
and recognize the dangers that all of us
have if we allow extremism and for
unforgiving judgmentalism and meanness
to polarize these churches so that
moderation What I Call Purple in a world
of everybody trying to be more red and
blue purple
not just that but even if you're red or
if you're blue for you to not think that
the red or the blue are evil and also to
help to have the courage to work across
lines of difference and to better
understand them not because you're going
to give up your values or conceit but
because by understanding you have a
chance of creating concrete progress
uh and there's like we just did a survey
Gary where 87 of Americans are fed up
with the polarization yeah I feel really
really fast tense yeah extremism is uh
Eclipse it's a it's a yeah it's because
you know rubber neck you know when
everything's fine on the highway
you're not paying attention to anybody
else but when there's an accident
everybody's rubber necking you know it's
funny one of the big mantras within my
own company I talk a lot about is and
versus or
and that's what you're referring to
which is like it just doesn't have to be
that way the world is not that small the
world is so big
you know you know the there's a lot of
entrepreneurs that one of the chapters
in my book I wrote a book called do the
kind of thing and the organizing
principles of a thinking with and rather
than we know I love that I mean it makes
so much sense why you had the success
like I love we are like like-minded
souls and I hope we don't make it boring
I hope you ask me tough questions well
here's a here's a here's a tough
question let's let's not make it boring
I
realized three four years ago that the
Kryptonite in my Unstoppable force of
you know human
skills was Candor which blew myself and
as I started talking about it people
that consume my content away because
garyvee is very good at Candor because
I'm speaking to the world I'm not having
a one-on-one conversation Gary
vaynerchuk the executive
really struggled with Candor because I
like optimism and happiness so much and
I was so capable
that I wasn't able to deliver Candor
because I thought it would lead to fear
and then and what it ended up leading to
was more fear because people didn't know
where they stood and that was a very
sombering moment in my career so back to
not softball questions if I asked you
you've had this incredibly strong career
uh you clearly care about humanity and
you're a professional Juggernaut if I
asked you professionally
what the biggest vulnerability you have
now in hindsight what you struggled with
maybe you've gotten better maybe you're
going through your process of getting
better right now just being very
transparent naked
naked and I think it's first of all it's
somewhat related to yours but mine would
probably be accountability because I'm
very good at setting out Vision I'm very
good at getting people engaged I'm
actually very good at Candor with
kindness and I would like to actually
talk about those I thought that's what
you were going to go it's a really good
inside with you thank you you have a
couple of thoughts on that please but
mine is uh following through with my
team and holding all of us accountable
like just my Approach is like aim for
the stars and I actually
if we don't line there we're not here
with it just do give it our very very
best right that to a degree good but
like Ellie Lanning who's my uh partner
in uh equilibrium adventures and a lot
of the work we're doing she used to be
my most important team members of kind
she she's much more about
tracking ourselves and holding ourselves
accountable I think that's an area where
I have a big opportunity do you can I
can I can I double click into that
because I think we are very like-minded
do you believe because this is a nuanced
one for some of the people listening
do you believe that there's a Nuance
there that might I think might be a huge
Insight because a lot of entrepreneurs
are going to listen to this over
especially over the next 50 years
do you believe that in that it's because
you're being so creative and so
ambitious because I always say it all
the time too let's shoot for the moon
and if we end up on the town top of
Mount Everest we did well it's better
than being here on the floor do you
believe that has something to do with
lots of objectives at the same time so
when I hear you talk about holding
people accountable I have a similar
thing
but it's because I know that I'm asking
people to do 47 things and I know that
29 are going to be really damn good
eight are going to be solid and 10 are
probably not going to go anywhere do you
feel like subconsciously or even in the
way I'm asking you this question if
you're reflecting really quick that
there was maybe something in there as
well or no
I think it's fundamentally because you
and I are entrepreneurs rather than
business managers correct so you know
there's a difference between being an
inventor an entrepreneur a business
manager an inventor has enormous amount
of creativity but no execution power
they come up with great ideas but they
don't correct
a business manager has an incredible
Talent at getting things done but they
don't have the left side of the brain as
developed an entrepreneur has a balance
between those and entrepreneurs will
never be as good as an inventor as a
business manager at that specific thing
but they're really good at the balance
of them and for it to work for an
entrepreneur you do need a ton of
creative ideas you need to try things
and fail and be okay with it and I think
we're good at trying things out and
encouraging our team to try things out
and we're okay with failure we're okay
with but it's not always so easy like my
temperament and my Approach worked
really well most times of kind but
sometimes like when kind was double
digit growing and triple digit growing
every year for I'm sorry triple digits
we're running over 100 for 10 years in a
row and so we're always exceeding goals
my goal my Approach was totally fine but
when we aimed to grow triple digits and
all of a sudden we only grew 89 or we
wanted to grow 80 that would grow 30 or
anything like that
to some of my team members it was very
demotivating that they didn't keep their
goals and I'm like who cares
let's just focus on putting in the best
work in and yeah it's in some situations
it can get us into trouble make sense in
two or three years in a row you don't
meet your goals to certain team members
it can be demotivated yes yeah but the
fact that what I would do then is
because people are very working very
high and we're still growing like crazy
just not what I would go I would still
pay people their full bonuses so it
wouldn't be about that but it's not
about that is people that are
competitive they want to meet their
goals I want to feel good about it but
did they not understand that the goals
were completely subjective
personality from many people and in
certain people and organizations sales
organizations
and and I used to have this debate with
with one of my friends that was sales
rep and say well why are we aiming so
long he said you think these people that
you've hired are so high driven are
gonna stop if they get the goal set the
right goal don't know how do you call it
uh sandbagit don't sandbag it uh I
always forget it
I need to uh
origin I'm working with your team Gary
on this series that's really funny where
we call my when I come up with really
dumb things earlier today I said we need
to roll in the sleeves of the white it
was rolling up well it's it's so funny
it's not um and I want to take the word
dumb out I'll tell you why I was born I
know you are I know you are but I want
everybody to hear it it's really funny I
can't believe you're this is gonna be a
fun this is so fun my family obviously I
was born in Belarus
and so when you just said that it's
there's maybe not I got warm when you
just said the what when you just said a
saying slightly different than it is in
English because you it's not your first
language you I wish technology was in a
place where I could press a button and
show everybody how warm that sentence
just made me feel which is why I'm
jumping in
my family had through the years has so
many fun moments with each other because
my parents even I even I
uh have some fun I say things that
aren't actually right but they become
ours I remember my favorite one was my
mom and my aunt kept talking about sauce
they're like get the sauce get the sauce
and at a certain point I was old enough
where they would ask me to get it and
they're like go get the sauce and I
would like open the refrigerator and
looking for like sauce and my mom be
like no sauce sauce and I never knew
what it meant and then finally there was
this moment where because I'd usually
just go run and play but then finally my
mom did it in front of me she opened up
the drawer and it was SOS the thing that
like clear cleans
and like me and my sister and so like
I'm sure all the immigrants would have a
big smile right now because born in the
U.S or you also were born in rivers I
was born in Belarus
yeah but you have no accent how I was I
was three that's why I don't have an
accent I was three but as you but when
we were talking about this I think
um you want to have also for our
audience on ADHD person we're going so
many different directions and for some
people setting very clear goals of
course it's very very important 100 my
belief is that putting players in a
position to succeed and reverse
engineering themselves them not how we
are absolutely on the flip side and I'm
sure you have a lot of pride in this
some of the greatest enjoyment in my
life today professionally sits and
taking people that were That Type A
and seeing that eight years later some
of me has rubbed off on them on osmosis
and I'll tell you where the joy comes
from and I have a funny feeling you're
going to resonate with this and this is
for all the leaders listening to where
some of the benefits can come from
a lot of times it's eliminated a lot of
anxiety for a lot of those people I get
a lot of Pride walking around and being
and I look at people there's one sitting
right outside of me right now I'm like
she's less anxious today than she was
seven years ago because she was two
black and white and she's Fallen a
little in love with gray and I love that
through my years I've gotten a little
more black and white back to your point
and and that's kind of the game
yeah what I what I love from what you
said is when my team members tell me
that they accomplished far more than
they ever thought was possible because I
challenge them and I do people think
that because and I'm gonna go back to
Canada please people think that because
you're kind a lot of people equate it
with weakness and they equate kindness
with niceness and the culture we created
a kind our company and the approach that
I have in life is to clarify that
there's a big difference between being
nice and being kind
to be nice
you are polite
you don't need strength you can you can
be a nice person it's not a bad thing
but you don't need to have the strength
of kindness to be kind you need to be
honest and to be honest you need that
candle that you're talking about that
requires a lot of strength like if
somebody has something in their truth
and you meet them in a party if you're
nice you don't tell them what you want
to make them feel comfortable but if
you're kind you invade their space and
say you have something here and that
takes strength but guess what you
actually help them more and so providing
feedback feedback and being candid in
your job and creating that yes certain
debate environment is essential but you
do it with you know what we I can call
hungry and kind values right I love that
number of authenticity
Earnest debate without me yeah that's
absolutely right I love that Daniel for
more fun to put teeth into this
interview in the last 10 15 years in
popular business culture
that's how I'll frame it so hopefully
I'll get you there what do you think you
were most wrong about with consumers
because I think you have a great
strength with it so if something that's
working today
that you just didn't see coming never
would have believed moved your
organizations or your Investments or
your behaviors against it but it became
true with the consumer if I said that
question which company maybe a company
that was wildly successful that you
thought had no chance anything stand up
bro there are two or three different
things that came to mind from Salt yeah
please
one was just in terms of cultures it's
really really funny but this is almost
like now become so everybody knows this
but
in January of 2020
we require everybody to be in the office
five days a week and I remember my prior
President John Leahy one of my best
friends and mentors used to really
insist that we couldn't even give them
Fridays off to work from home because a
lot of people in the New York choice
that area had three-hour commutes each
way so some people like can we work out
of home on Fridays and John was like no
hands all hands on deck we all need to
be here feel empty osmosis yes today
many people work out of their homes
maybe people coming to their office two
or three days a week maybe sometimes
they don't even go as much and it's a
very high performing culture everybody's
proven that that it that we had it wrong
about that so in terms of cultural yeah
in terms of Trends I have so many
stories of like the way I created time
is because I looked for something that I
needed help you reverse engineered
yourself right
so I tend to approach uh consumer
product good opportunities and
Investments I think if it fits me but
I've missed a ton of them as a result
like many of them like somebody
approached me with the idea to create an
old based beverage 10 15 years ago and
I'm like why would anybody want to take
oats and turning into a garbage how
stupid is that not a drink oat milk all
the time yeah my friends are invested in
their company and but it's a whole
industry right now there's so many
companies in that space and it's a
billion dollar space yes I didn't see it
and I can give you 10 more examples
where I I didn't see uh things that have
a place to say
I'm fine with
ignoring fads in your industry those the
Technologies for me these special diets
that are like I think for three months I
I don't
feel like we've lost anything by
avoiding those but there are sustainable
uh trends that I did not
see and and they were very effective in
your childhood
did you
know that you were an entrepreneur
yes why well I didn't know that I was an
entrepreneur I just love
entrepreneurship right right
right right when I was eight years my
father was an entrepreneur my I saw him
built himself from nothing he arrived to
Mexico with nothing here third grade
education he had been in a concentration
camp liberated by American soldiers
being a refugee came to Mexico speaking
Spanish and English building himself
from nothing educating himself from
nothing and so I had I think absorbed
from him or watched or maybe was genetic
I don't know all of the above Pride the
way yes I used to do magic shows as a
kid I used to do when I was 16 years old
I started selling watches and all sorts
of charge kissing in
um
uh flea markets that's that's that's why
all this stuff you see behind me I was
incredibly affected by that culture
I was yes like sports cards flea markets
garage sales like if I was a generation
older I would have been a shemata
monster you know you know I I need to go
back to the
flea market where I started as a 16 year
old because I didn't have my family came
to America lawfully because my dad had a
business but I didn't have the right to
work so I couldn't get all my friends
were taking how old were you waiters and
waitresses and I got blocky that I
couldn't get that so I created my own so
I started selling these things
eventually I was selling at kiosks in
shopping malls and I had all my college
students helping uh I love that provide
all the scheduling and work you know
we're at like 10 team members how old
were you when you came
15 and a half and that was to wear in
America
to the cradle of civilization San
Antonio Texas that's amazing amazing I
don't come at it because I was I loved
coming to America I love the United
States I mean with all of its failings I
think it's the most amazing country on
Earth sure is like contrasted to my
father's experience of course
uh but when we came to San Antonio if
you were late three days if you had
three parties they would give you legs
then they would take this big stick and
they would really hit you yeah this was
in 1984 so it was like whoa you know
this is the land the critters San
Antonio wasn't [ __ ] around in 84 huh
and uh but you know that was a public
school or was that a like a religious
school a public school Robert E Lee High
School well you have to get you have to
get a permission from your parents but
the alternative was that you were going
to be in a study hall with ax murderers
so I'm like let me get those three legs
because I don't want to be right right
that's amazing but you asked earlier
about something that I didn't see coming
Gary and speak a little seriously when I
immigrated to America
to the land of opportunity to a lot of
freedom yeah a lot of bipartisan respect
I it never crossed my mind that would
end up being as worried as I am about
our country as I am today yeah I end up
my parents my parents my parents talk
about the same thing they're like never
thought they would worry about the
things they have to worry about now
yeah and I used to apply my efforts for
Bill bridging in the Middle East and
other parts of the world and now I feel
like we really need to build the toolkit
of values yeah
daily habits well you know you know we
talked about it earlier my friend I'm
sorry to jump in but I want to get your
perspective on this and I don't want to
run out of time because we're wrapping
up
um
we've lost the art of Civility
you know I think about that a lot
watching grown-ups interact with each
other around politics and the
politicians themselves
was like unacceptable by fifth graders
when I was growing up
yeah like I'm watching the main calling
and I'm like of course like where are
like where how have we gotten here and
you know look I think there's a million
variables that get one to somewhere but
like
you know yeah I mean I think a lot of us
back to your 87 are unhappy like even my
most Stark fully left fully right
friends and I have plenty of both
because I'm a very purple guy
even I can sense in them and I'm talking
the ones that have been the loudest to
get us into the far left and the far
right
even with them I'm noticing I'm on
October 27th of an election midterm
election year
the fatigue I sense from far left and
far right actually has me optimistic a
little bit
because it's [ __ ] hard to fight
it takes a lot of energy because what
what makes us a great country what makes
us the most entrepreneurial Nation with
the most Freedom there's an underlying
oil that glue that tells you've been
running yes and it's Timeless it's
respect its civility as you were playing
if you do not have kindness respect and
civility you lose the effectiveness and
you're working environment you don't
have a high performing culture because
you cannot be candid because you feel
like you're going to be canceled and
you're going to be destroyed so that
you're like holding back everybody
classroom or in the college or in the
workplace if you don't have the ability
to create transparency earnestness uh
Candor uh trust openness it requires
that
yeah that new one a hundred percent that
positive intent it it will destroy all
of us it will destroy not just our of
course
and what the solution is that I helped
co-founder movement called starts with
us starts with us
starts with us that everybody should
join because you don't stop and you
don't know what to do about it go look
at starts with DOT us there's a ton of
things that you can do to help us build
the movement for the 87 percent the 87
that recognize that both for us to be
better parents whether children more
effective in our workplace and more
effective citizen we need to work with
the three C's more curiosity more
compassion and more courage curiosity to
respect that we don't have all the
answers that other people may have
insights that we may not know that we
need more be more critical thinkers and
critical listeners compassion to just
put ourselves in other people's shoes
and just be a little bit more forgiving
a little bit less judgmental and the
courage to work across lines of
difference and that's you know
Echo Chambers on social media cable news
polarization devised politicians
designed the perfect storm to create a
lot of bad habits but the solutions like
you said Gary more than 87 of Americans
are fed up and it's up to all of us
every single day to work a little bit at
a time on
showing those daily habits and if we do
we are going to bring our country back
to incredible changes but but we really
all need to take hold of it we cannot
wait for somebody else to do it for us I
couldn't agree more tell me a story
early on from a mentor or a consumer one
of the two in the first 10 you know
maybe uh in a like a famous Daniel story
at the flea market you know in San
Antonio or a consumer story or a mentor
or as you were segwaying at 27 you mean
you met X give me a a story that you
think shaped you being in this place
today that's outside of your family
outside of your dad outside of your DNA
and your upbringing
uh Gary this is a great question I have
like a thousand in my mind I'll try I'll
try to do one that's actually not in
business but it's the one that came the
most over me
um when I was
just uh before we launched the kind
brand
I I I'd love to tell you those other
story also but please do both when I was
doing peace Works to bring people
together
and we were trying to get Israelis and
Palestinians to work together
and all of a sudden there was a Spate of
bombings and terrorist attacks where
there was this uh Passover Massacre
where a lot of Jewish families were
killed and in parallel I had a lot of
Palestinian friends that were suffering
enormously from the occupation you were
just seeing so much suffering and in the
meantime I was like trying to get
Palestinians and Israelis to work
together and I approached my Israeli
empathy and friends because I felt shame
embarrassed that I was doing this I felt
like I was living a lie and I talked to
my Israeli and Palestinian friends and I
said to my suppliers I said look guys
meru should put a pause on this because
I know this was based on my college
thesis and my law school work I would
bring people together but when you look
at reality it takes one Extreme as one
violent extremist to blow up people and
really derail everything and maybe maybe
you should not be encouraging this work
and maybe we're we don't have the
legitimacy to be pursuing this at this
time and my Israeli and Palestinian
Partners were Furious of me and there's
like Daniel what are you talking about
this is no longer
college thesis and intellectual
study this is our lives are you going to
abandon us now because one person does
something crazy this is all the more so
we need to double down and not give up
and not allow
voice of extremism to hijack the
president rule Our Lives we need to
double down and never give up and it was
like a wake-up call to where I've gone
for the last I don't know 25 30 years
since then because it made me realize
the danger of allowing extremism to rule
Our Lives because the problem there is
that even if we have 87 percent of
people that are moderate and have a
purple or no one's thought and they
certainly don't want to dehumanize the
other and that includes blue and red of
course of course blue man and
independently progressing and
conservative but they're people that are
humans it's a very very tiny probably
things less than 10 that are like so
extremist the problem is that extremists
wake up in the morning and they think
how can I Advance my cause that's right
and moderates wake up in the morning and
they think
what can I have for breakfast
and that's a fundamental difference like
it's it's the biggest it's the
population yeah it's the biggest reason
that I think people that are happy need
to be louder you just everything you
just said is the single reason I make
content
I think people that are happy and want
others to be happy have a responsibility
to also produce unlimited con I wake up
every morning and don't say what am I
gonna have for breakfast I say what am I
gonna say this morning
that's going to get one person that's
disenfranchised to realize how awesome
it is to even be a human being that if
they start getting rid of their grudges
grudges hurt you not the person you have
a grudge on
every day I'm trying to convince one
person
that life is a billion times better than
they've decided because they were
unfortunate to have life situations or
most common cynical or pessimistic
or negative parents and circumstances
that made them believe the propaganda of
negativity
and let's add that once they recognize
that power
that they have they also have a
responsibility
to use that power because the stakes are
very high for all of us well the pro the
problem the problem is people that are
happy are content playing within their
circle of the 50 people they're with
people that to your point this people
that are the most unhappy right now are
the loudest and most aggressive to have
misery loves company and get them in and
it's on both sides Gary can you tell me
one fun story of any of your things in
the back there's so many fun things
about there I'll tell you one fun story
all these be friends which is my nft
project intellectual property my for 13
years I've been building Vayner this
company
and all my smartest friends made fun of
me when I started it because they were
like why are you doing a client service
business like and they came from a nice
place I was 34 at the time they're like
you're so smart you could build such
great companies a client like they were
like genuinely disappointed
and I remember sitting quietly with
myself and said I'm self-aware I Know
Myself and I have a hypothesis that
communication is about to change
everything we're talking about
the rails of it are internet
communication and then the
vulnerabilities of mainstream media
becoming businesses versus being public
service providers and so it was just
very obvious to me the world was going
to change and the way kind was going to
build its brand was going to be
realistic in a world where before you
had to be Procter and Gamble or Nabisco
or craft to ever do it that the world
was changing and I said to myself using
Star Wars that if I build a
Communications Death Star the best
Communications engine in the world that
anything I pointed to your personal
brand
curing Crohn's disease because my
brother has it selling a wine brand it
was agnostic whatever I cared about I
could point my machine against rezzy the
restaurant app V friends that I could
build awareness and relevance at scales
that have never been seen before and so
these little characters you see these
are my characters that are like Sesame
Street and Pokemon and Disney and Marvel
that I'm building right
but it was that web3 came along and nfts
came along I always thought that I was
building this Communications Death Star
to buy
nostalgic Brands so I thought at this
point in my life I'd be buying Smurfs or
Hannah Barbera or what Bob Iger
unfortunately with many more resources
and with the same Brilliance he moved
faster with a lot more money on Marvel
and Lucas I didn't get to that and then
once he did that more people understood
their intellectual property was worth
more so my master plan of like buying
you know Gumby or or whatever it was
that I was gonna buy anyway
it the story is I is when you have a
macro Vision sometimes it's not exactly
how you drew it up I was going to build
the best Communications company in the
world and then I was going to act like
private equity and buy an intellectual
property and then extract the value
Bob Iger came along and showed the world
how underpriced Lucas and marble were
and then there was micro versions of
that going on I never got to achieve it
then a macro technology came along
called the blockchain that allowed me to
establish my own IP this character my
friend I could have bought Gumby
I could have bought Gumby
but if I put Gumby this character would
have never existed this my friend is a
character look what this is called
he's a bigger person we've just spent
the last 40 minutes as Alpha competitive
winners
talking about kindness and Humanity I
will make this character be the bigger
person which is now a toy you could buy
at Toys R Us inside of Macy's stores so
culturally relevant and popular
and that will sink into the subconscious
of every child and they will think it's
cool to be the bigger person versus the
world we live in now where people think
it's cool to tear down others
I love that but I also want to draw for
your audience uh I thought that's
actually a big parallel between you and
I
um somewhere in here I have this child
that if you find it if it's almost
hilarious because it has like a vision
of where when I built peace Works they
had all these different divisions that
was going to create all different things
I was going to do and it was like almost
delusional I mean I have
this Empire of Peace notes and kindness
and it was really if you saw it it's
it's actually funny but I had this
Vision but where I got lucky is that
Adventure learned that I needed to focus
and win big in one thing before I got
the right to then go elsewhere it sounds
like and if you do that it's not only
okay every television it's important for
your television and then things are
going to evolve a bit different but I
think it's kind of like where we started
like dream very very big then start
executing with your best intentions and
then you have one success and you can
build on that and you can building them
but the ultimate thing is that you do
need that creativity but you also need
that Focus for the immediate step right
to get that right because you build the
foremost firm in your space and that
gave you the right to go to the next
step
I love it
my friend this has been super enjoyable
I wish you nothing but health and
continued success really
same here Gary nice to talk to you we'll
talk soon I hope everybody enjoyed that
please dig in one more time the
organization because I think a lot of
people are going to be clicking
starts with us and it starts with DOT us
for all you uh
executors of urls
Daniel thank you again my friend we'll
talk soon
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]